origin PC and creep is back in action
baby yes I really like origin PC and I'm
thrilled to have them back as sponsors
and to celebrate this continued
partnership we're giving a week not just
anything okay
we're giving away invidious new Archie
x20 atti tide and whatever BAM which is
available on Origin PC Bam Bam Bam Bam
you could win this and it's a worldwide
giveaway that's right doesn't matter if
you're India or anywhere else in the
planet you could win this it will run
for three weeks from the start date to
sign up head over to Origin PC comm /p -
pi link in description
bro and I gotta flex on you kids a
little bit as well origin PCs gonna
build me a brand new RT X beats which I
can of course used to watch memes hey I
need that okay and it's gonna be built
in there all new neuron which of course
I know what that means because I watch
memes old thing but you can check it out
on their website make sure to follow me
and Oranje pc on their social media for
more information this video was
sponsored by Oren - PC check out link in
description
keep watching video now bye ok the
bullying hit when this app has gotten
way out of hand
you only need to grow up and quit
picking on people you want to mess with
somebody come mess with me yep this man
may be there let's begin the main
challenge
tik-tok bullying means is they're
growing exponentially
finally a mean that is not dying alright
it's still going strong
twice tick tock means because you have a
job doesn't mean that your life is not
much harder than anybody else's sorry to
say it runner but
what else is new you wanna know what you
I have cancer some fun no it's not it's
really not what it is the new form of
emo these kids lives are they're so
privileged that they have to reenact
this drama drama
- sighs dramas dramatic sighs drama good
job Felix soap opera whatever kids watch
okay you know what this reminds me up
you know what it's time for guys I think
it's time for an announcement everyone
we have an announcement to make
so oh yeah if this kid is not in YouTube
rewind I'm gonna be it never gets old
this click never gets over for me I love
it so much if only if only he could be
President instead of that orange thinks
would be better is this is this the meme
now is he actually gonna become a meme
I love it so much I love it so much
what do you what during our work diets
what are you what are you how are you
wait wait that's how you know you're
dead for reals
man if I see venom don't care if I see
then you know I'm dead fantastic the
vendor meme everybody the first week of
this meme English someone saved me
please how are you
I don't know it's one of those means you
can literally put anything in it and it
will still be funny guys I don't know if
you guys knew this but you could put any
meme in there and it will still be
hilarious I'll show it to you how are
you welcome to five nights at Freddy's
yeah slay me doc applier slay me now I
make I know this is gonna take out I
have that feeling I am feel passionate
about this mean well that's the alert of
this meme is gonna grow in the stock
market invest invest right now send all
your money to this mean it's gonna a
quickly explode what day are you
today damn that's an epic face filter
damn
Mark Zuckerberg how did you even do that
large tribe made a template of this if
you guys want to download that what the
hell are you so you can make your own
version I'm sure I'm sure people are
gonna come up with some pretty cool
stuff
what the hell are you oh yeah
it doesn't get better than these guys if
you want to make your own version of
this just check out link into the
description and you can make one to the
vendor meme gets a it's not quite
regular it's a little toasty but I think
it's not time and you have to be
responsible you have to know when things
are ready and when they are not you know
what I mean okay I pick a rake I pick a
rake no no one's done man in between
memes memes everybody that's right memes
are so scarce these things I have to
drag it out with the segment Wemyss
maybe I should just do a separate meme
show where I just focus on any mean you
know what I don't think I need another
meme show actually maybe a meme
shout-out how about that you know we
have the flex fans meme and you have the
the pro-life mean come by what's up flex
fans we're gonna check out the new
green-screen
it's awesome I think you're gonna love
it and as much as I love both they don't
really deserve their own segment on
bonus meme I mean on meme review so hey
I'm just throwing that out there
when I grew up I want to own a dinosaur
chuckles from back of classroom that's
literally impossible it's just me man it
would be so great if Ben Shapiro would
host me review that would literally be
epic vision this meme with like a
Japanese dub bah
I really it's funny in my head next
me this is another meme that it's it's
just getting there it's it's a the seeds
have been planted but it's not quite
growing yet and I don't think it will
grow that big because you can't really
be that right just show the meaning
Felix okay all right
evolution can you give me a hand
manipulation to polish rocks DNA to
polish rocks
yes actually crap stuff to destroy
everything like a box human time well I
mean I think they're funny okay
all right if you didn't like this one
you'll love this one evolution can you
give me lungs for lion to live on land
yes actually goes back to water like a
boss when time oh yeah okay all right
how about this one evolution can you
give me horns to defend your seat
yes actually gets killed from actually
gets killed for the horn by humans like
a bounds extinction extinction washed my
hair the DNA me get set in conclusion
see I kill the memes even before they're
ready me review and then when you're
gonna watch it on us again I watch you
buffoon a service howl yeah
yes your leader honor me okay daddy
[Laughter]
can I please have gills so I can drink
water and for you to drink water and
breathe
Yates actually drinks beer like a boss
beer time
beer time next
meh-meh everybody whoa hold it right
there you watch this video without
smashing like and subscribe
that is not ethically being asleep
realizing birds aren't bu but birds are
birds are real right so I got a Google
this bird prototype surely this can't be
erect what's the difference between
these two birds absolutely
belief in birds was angel is London
welcome back to some quick headlines
China takes spine to new heights the
country now reportedly using drones that
look like real birds similar to this
video reportedly these drones are
equipped with cameras GPS antennas and
data links to communicate their findings
back to Chinese intelligence you
freaking kidding me how deep does this
go hurts our drones Birds truthers the
government
god my chills level is goin
exponentially stronger birds birds
troopers united states population maybe
pigeons
why don't you ever see baby pigeons oh
my god I've never seen a baby pigeon I
have never seen a baby pigeon
how can birds be real if baby pigeons
aren't real birds aren't real
open your eyes and smash like if you've
never seen a baby pigeon this is
extremely important in this mean gets it
so no destruction this mean gets
destroyed I just I just felt like I had
to I'm sorry it's got to half left
though it's fine it's fine
next mean okay alright everybody we have
to finish off with the MPC meme I
already talked about it in pew news
this means started off by reddit I have
a theory that there is only a fixed
quantity of souls on planet earth that
cycles continuously through
reincarnation
however since human growth rate is so
severe okay you get it all right yeah
I've already explained it I shouldn't
have to explain it again basically
you're an MPC if you like Marvel movies
if you if you like video games come on
if you listen to Adele I got bad news
for you if you listen to tej wait Taylor
Swift I got bad news for you
if you watch it Jackson again markiplier
the fine brothers I got bad news for you
you're an MVC are you a PC or NPC and
busy please western games like Super
Mario Sunshine what are you a child I
bet you never lifted any weights in your
life pathetic plays on easy I bet you
can't even get past a cup head tutorial
reports toxic behavior only tries to
beat the game Wow
watches Sony movies gaming journalists
Oh tank or healer
oh I like tank oh no DPS is MPC get out
of here with
okay hey if you guys ever use any of
these words I got bad news for you
problem man
yikes yeah loosing all humanity what
what does that do in there
who ratted that one in there I will not
stand for it I am NOT an NBC Hey look at
that
everyone has an Apple computer Wow think
different am i right now this meme got
popular because they pull it got
politicized it's not a word probably
isn't people started using it as a way
to define it to troll lip tarts epic
style and then lip tars response of
course is with even better memes just
kidding it's your dick humanizing me
stop dehumanizing me you Russian bonds
stupid Russian vibes ruin my marriage
it's like the new things Abama it's
Russian box honey it's the food ready
soon same with Russian box
NPC meme is dehumanizing we are all
unique in spacial you even got so far
that the New York Times yes
the New York Times ahead to specify are
these Russian box or these memes these
Twitter accounts actually Russian but
probably not thank you
reddit user creates an PC Bojack meme
boy everyone is stupid but me meme
summarized everybody there you go I feel
like the embassy meme had so much
potential but it's already been I can't
maybe I'll chuckle one I got I got one
or two chuckles left in me I'm not gonna
lie I wanted to rate it high I wanted
this to be the movement I think tick
tock memes is our only real hope out
there to be honest I think that's all we
got are really trying to and she'll
forth so that's it for me review and now
it's always I'm gonna pass on the
question to you guys what do you think
leave a comment down below I want to
know everything though every single
comment I will 100% read cuz do my fam
you're my bro Sookie now
please your fist on the side of the
screen and we're going to end this
episode with an epic breakfast are you
ready broth main review see you next
week boys and no carbs
[Music]